please hear me on this you can't
outthink anxiety you can't sit in a dark
room and get all the right thoughts in
the right order and neglect your
[Music]
[Applause]
body so when I think back to when I was
completely burned to the ground with
anxiety with burnout with just chronic
stress day after day after day I had a
whole bunch of graduate degrees I was
surrounded by some of the smartest Minds
in the world and I committed myself to
solving anxiety but all along the way I
completely neglected the vessel that was
carrying me all over the place I started
skipping workouts I started eating junk
food in garbage I stopped seeing a
counselor cuz I didn't have time I had
these feelings about things that
happened to me in the past and I shoved
them down because I had important
intellectual work to do and my body was
sick
my body was overcome with past
traumas my body said I
quit we're a culture that has
information on everything a blog post
and a Wikipedia page and a YouTube
channel for everything we can imagine
for most of us our pain won't be solved
with more intellect our pain is solved
by sitting down and exhaling and to look
at our one precious body and say you're
worth taking care
of
so when I talk about healing I'm often
talking about dealing with past trauma
and we think of trauma like the big
carreck right the big plane crash right
those big before and after moments and
that is trauma that's acute but there's
also other kinds of trauma like
secondary trauma if you are a nurse
You're a social worker you're a
counselor every day people come to you
and say will you please help me and so
we're in a acute trauma might be like
somebody dropping a cinder block in your
backpack cumulative trauma is the
everyday somebody comes in hands you a
few Pebbles and the next day a few
Pebbles the next day a few Pebbles and
over time the weight of that backpack is
the exact same as the weight of somebody
with a cinder block there's also
Collective trauma what happens when a
whole country goes to war or when I
don't know an illness sweeps across the
globe right that's a collective trauma
that we all experience together and then
there's another kind of trauma that we
don't talk about very often the trauma
of neglect the things you should have
got when you were a kid you should have
had a safe place to come home to from
school Dad should have chosen you over
the bottle mom should have chosen you
over the cell phone and what happens is
our body puts a GPS pin in those moments
and 25 years later you get married and
you found the Romantic partner of your
dreams and they get close to you and
your body says whoo we remember what
happens when someone gets close and it
sounds the alarms that guy is not safe
she's going to hurt us too how many of
you feel 2 in apart from someone but
2,000 Mi away from them and healing from
trauma is almost always about teaching
your body I know we weren't safe then we
got hurt badly back
then but we're going back in now and we
might get hurt again cuz vulnerability
is the only path to friendship and love
and con nection but that's the path to
Healing from
[Music]
trauma so when I talk about health I'm
talking about your physical body and
it's time we're honest as a country
we're way overweight our metabolic
health is a mess and there is no mental
health without physical health you can't
build a home without first building a
foundation and a foundation to grow
great mental and emotional health is
having a healthy body if you have
chronic pain if you're struggling with
obesity if your joints hurt your neck
hurts your back hurts it's almost
impossible to have good mental and
emotional
health few things are more contentious
than the nutrition religion Wars that
are upon us I'm keto well I'm vegan well
I'm carnivore well I'm rational and
sensible enough what you're going to
find is that for most people most of the
time hold your hats just about any diet
we do
if you make some hard choices about
consumption and movement we've created a
world for ourselves we don't have to
move very much we take escalators up the
stairs we take escalators down we fly in
Planes cross country almost overnight
we've withdrawn movement from The Human
Experience it's it's killing us and so
if you want to choose a non-anxious life
you have to choose movement and like
nutrition I'm not going to get into the
workout Wars it can be a 20m run it can
be a walk to your mailbox and back it
can be a 10minute wait room session in
your garage I don't care you have to
move most of us know the data we should
all be getting about 7 to 9 hours of
sleep and we also know that most of us
think we're pretty hardcore and we're
doing just fine on four five or 6 hours
of sleep for 99.9% of us we're not our
bodies aren't getting that deep wave
restorative sleep our bodies aren't
getting that deep REM sleep that takes
out the garbage in our minds that
restores and heals our body and prepares
us for the next day and for many of us
sleep is hard we have racing thoughts
we've got things to do we've got kids
running everywhere and yet if we don't
prioritize sleep everything else in our
life will suffer the less sleep you get
especially over time the more anxious
you're bound to
[Music]
feel being perfect getting it all done
accomplishing Health accomplishing
healing is the Fool's errand you'll
never be all the way there wouldn't it
be awesome if we could brush our teeth
once a week we could do it so good on
Monday morning that we didn't have to
brush our teeth for the rest of the week
that would be amazing we can't I got to
do it twice a day similarly when you
choose health and healing you make that
choice for the rest of your life some
days it's harder some days it's easier I
showed up to this shoot today these guys
they brought a box of donuts I chose a
donut right but it's part of a bigger
picture this my life most of the time
health and healing should be relatively
simple it's
hard it's a complete 180 from how most
of us live our lives but if you just
think am I being a good Steward of what
I'm putting in my body am I moving am I
willing to sit down across from somebody
and say I got hurt bad and here's what
happened very very hard things but
simple things and if you feel yourself
complicated or if you feel yourself
sitting with a professional and they're
telling you this and this and this and
this maybe time to move on because the
truest masterminds will tell you it's
just three or four or five or six
buckets over and over and over
again just like brushing your teeth
choosing health and healing is a choice
you're going to make every day for the
rest of your
life you're worth that
choice